Donald Trump
hush money and a potential indictment
that could be coming soon.
The New York Times is reporting
that the district attorney's office
here in
Manhattan is signaling
Trump will likely face
criminal charges over hush money payments
to the adult film actress Stormy Daniels.
But this is not a slam dunk.
The case could pose a big challenge
for prosecutors
The Times reports
the former president was told
that he could appear
before a Manhattan grand jury next week
if he wishes to testify,
a strong indication
that an indictment could soon
follow Trump has repeatedly denied
having an affair with Stormy Daniels,
and he denies telling his longtime
fixer, Michael Cohen,
to buy her silence for $130,000.
Right before the 2016
presidential election.
But Cohen insists
that he has the receipts, personal checks
signed by the former president
to reimburse him.
Our senior legal affairs
correspondent is Paula.
She's following the story
for us this morning in Washington.
Good morning to you.
The D.A.
is giving Trump the chance to testify.
Do you think he'll take it?
I do not.
Don, we know that his lawyers
have recently met
with the district attorney
and they're concerned
because we're seeing this uptick
in activity in this investigation.
This probe has been going on
for about five years.
But in recent weeks, we've
suddenly seen this parade of high profile
witnesses, close
associates of the former president
like Kellyanne Conway and Hope Hicks.
Going to testify before this grand jury?
I do not think it is likely
that the former president
will join that parade of witnesses going
before the grand jury.
And a statement last night
a spokesperson for the former president
dismissed this whole thing
as, quote, insane.
But the fact that the invitation
has been extended
signals that this investigation
is likely wrapping up
and that an indictment is possible.
So, Paula,
this is obviously a major development,
but it's a complicated legal theory
that the Manhattan attorney
is trying to apply here.
There are a lot of lot
hinges on Trump's
former attorney, Michael Cohen,
who has been convicted.
Right. And has served time.
So is it a strong case
and is anyone even know at this point?
Look, we know a lot about this, right?
Because this case has been out there
for years.
Some people,
some of these have been investigated
some have been charged.
So we do know a lot of the basic facts
of this case.
Look, Don, it's a fact.
This conduct is approximately
seven years old at the court.
This is a paperwork crime
that would have to be prosecuted
on a pretty novel
legal theory in New York.
And the witness at the center of all
this is Michael Cohen.
And, Don,
you know, you've interviewed Cohen.
You've spoken with him
every time he speaks in public.
The issue of the former
president comes up
and he appears pretty arguably fixated
on former
President Trump
being charged in any good defense
attorney would seize on that
and the fact that he is a convicted liar
to try to undermine his credibility.
And you really need a credible witness
to support a case like this.
So the larger question is, well,
why is the district attorney
digging back into this?
Now, we know that he's
under a lot of political pressure.
It's always possible
that they have unearthed
some additional evidence.
But based on what we know now,
this is not the strongest case
that the former president
is possibly
facing as compared
to something
like down in Georgia,
where they're looking in
to his efforts to interfere
with the election outcome there.
You have multiple witnesses.
You have recordings, you have documents,
something like that.
Even though former president's
attorneys will admit
they are much more concerned about that.
But he did go to jail
for actually brokering this deal.
You see, when he went here,
he had a lot of legal problems,
personal legal problems
with the IRS, with his business dealings
beyond just this hush money payment.
And I think intelligent minds
can disagree
whether the National Enquirer right.
Did not get enough accountability
for this.
But again,
at this point, it's just about the case
against the former president.
And it is not terribly strong
based on the facts that we know.
But, of course, we don't know everything.
Right on. Thank you, Paula.
Can we talk about this
possible indictment?
Not a slam dunk.
Everyone's like, is it coming?
Is it coming?
We don't know for sure.
But that's what they said.
The winds are heading that way.
What's your what's your response to this?
You know, not not a lawyer.
This is probably the case
that Trump's least afraid of
of the plethora of lawsuits,
of different investigations
he's facing to
within the Department of Justice.
The Eugene Carroll
case, the Fulton County case.
This is one
that they're
Trumpworld is prepared to hit back
if it goes the way
that we're anticipating to say this is
this is the liberals
still trying to undo the 2016 election
this is seven years ago.
This is a weak campaign finance case.
So I don't know that
I think this is some kind of a slam dunk.
My other caution is this Trump's
usually emboldened
when he looks like he's under attack
as we saw after the Mar a Lago raid.
Even really mainstream Republicans
the Dan Crenshaw is the Marco Rubio.
Rubio kind of rallied around
Donald Trump saying
this is unprecedented.
This is an overstep of justice.
I anticipate you may see this.
They said he wasn't going to run until.
I don't know if that's true.
But remember,
they said he wasn't going to run
until that raid happened
and then this sort of emboldened
him, like, I'm going to definitely do it
emboldens his base because he
he positions himself.
You know, I am your retribution.
I am taking these fears
and arrows for you.
I think it honestly may help him Doesn't
mean justice shouldn't be served,
but something like
this is hardly going to be
Trump's undoing.